[Musique]
et cet invité depuis bruxelles
aujourd'hui c'est vous françois gemenne
bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes chercheur
spécialiste en géopolitique de
l'environnement vous avez co dirigé la
guerre chaude qui vient de sortir aux
presses de sciences po plus que
d'actualité on va y revenir dans
quelques instants c'est d'abord aux
spécialistes des questions de migration
que vous n'êtes que je m'adresse
françois gemenne deux millions de
personnes ont fui l'ukraine en moins de
deux semaines sans parler des déplacés
internes dans le pays s'ils le plus
grand exode en europe depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale ou en tout cas le plus
rapide comment un pays comme la pologne
peut accueillir en quelques jours
décemment si l'on peut dire plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes
ça va être le grand défi pour la pologne
et pour les pays voisins on estime que
dans dans le premier afflux de réfugiés
la grande majorité était hébergé chez
des proches chez de la famille et ce
sont parmi les premiers réfugiés qui ont
fui la question maintenant c'est de
savoir comment on va faire pour
accueillir ceux qui n'ont pas de famille
ceux qui n'ont pas de proches en pologne
qui sont dans des centres d'hébergement
et cela sans doute ou va s'imposer la
nécessité d'un plan de répartition de
ces réfugiés sur le continent européen
et donc paradoxalement alors que des
pays comme la pologne était jadis vent
debout contre toutes les propositions de
plan de répartition des réfugiés
proposée par la commission européenne
notamment au moment de l'exode des
réfugiés syriens il se pourrait cette
fois ci que la pologne et plus
globalement les pays du groupe de
visegrad donc là la pologne la tchéquie
la slovaquie et la hongrie voir
l'intérêt à ce plan de répartition cette
crise pourrait aussi faire bouger les
lignes européennes en matière de
politique d'asile et d'immigration
d'autant qu'il ya le très court terme et
puis il ya le plus long terme on est
loin d'être certain évidemment que ces
exilés une craignent un pur ou voudront
retourner dans l'émoi dans les années
qui arrivent dans leur pays
bien entendu aujourd'hui la plupart des
exilés espère pouvoir retourner
rapidement en ukraine mais si cette
guerre s'installe dans la durée ce que
personne ne souhaite évidemment il va
falloir penser à des politiques
d'intégration sur du plus long terme
notamment en termes d'accès au marché du
travail et c'est là vraiment que le vrai
défi va commencer et la solidarité a été
immédiate françois gemenne à l'égard de
ces exilés ukrainien avec un effet
miroir sur l'accueil ou plutôt sur
l'absence d'accueil vous l'évoquez à
l'instant d'autres exilés sur le sol
européen on peut penser aux syriens ou
aux afghans ou encore plus récemment
comment est ce que vous le regardez
bien sûr il faut souligner la grande
générosité la solidarité et dans
l'accueil des ukrainiens mais ça
souligne aussi en creux notre incapacité
à réserver le même accueil à des
réfugiés qui venaient d'autres régions
du monde et l'explication elle est assez
simple c'est une explication de de
proximité c'est une guerre qui se passe
sur le continent européen
pour laquelle les européens se sentent
aussi concernés
et on a toujours tendance à vouloir
protéger davantage celui qu'on reconnaît
comme un proche comme un de ses
semblables et ça souligne aussi que
quelque part nous avions tendance à
moins protégés ce qui nous paraissait
davantage différents de nous parce qu'on
avait l'impression que cette crise nous
concerner moins ici évidemment il est le
sentiment que la crise concerne aussi et
en premier lieu les citoyens européens
les européens ont accordé à ces réfugiés
d'ukrainiens
il n'a quelque chose qui s'appelle une
protection immédiate qui malaise d'une
certaine façon des tracasseries
administratives
sa pêche beaucoup plus en revanche à
l'entrée du royaume uni la la solidarité
s'est heurté à l'épreuve des frontières
absolument alors il faut souligner que
c'est très rare il y a eu une limite et
en europe pour accorder cette protection
temporaire c'est une directive qui date
de 2001 et qu'il n'avait jamais été
appliquée auparavant et donc c'est une
des premières fois dans l'histoire
récente de l'union européenne qui lie à
une unanimité sur une question d'asile
et de migration est sain souligne aussi
effectivement le fait que la grande
bretagne n'a pas souhaité mettre en
place le même traitement et que quelque
part la grande bretagne reste un peu
figé dans ses positions sur l'asile et
l'immigration ça n'a pas fait bouger les
lignes en grand-bretagne diriez vous
françois gemenne que ce conflit ans en
ukraine et là c'est autre casquette que
je sollicite en celle du spécialiste en
géopolitique de l'environnement fait
aussi peser sur l'europe un risque
climatique majeure en ce sens que pour
se défaire de la dépendance aux
hydrocarbures russes les alternatives
évoqués ne sont pas toutes propres loin
de là je pense notamment à l'italie qui
n'exclut pas de réactiver ses centrales
à charbon
absolument et c'est vrai que l'option du
charbon est une option envisagée par
plusieurs pays européens et je dirais
que ça souligne à quel point nous avons
tardé à mettre en place une vraie
politique énergétique au niveau européen
et quelque part les alertes sur le
changement climatique aurait dû il y a
déjà vingt ou trente ans nous amener à
changer de politique et j'ai envie de
dire que nous avons été paresseux nous
nous sommes contentés d'acheter des
hydrocarbures la russie nous avons
enrichi les oligarques russes et de ce
fait nous nous sommes placés dans une
position de grande dépendance de grande
vulnérabilité vis-à-vis de la russie
alors on voit aujourd'hui que certains
pays sont un peu aculé est prêt à
changer leur fusil d'épaulé alors pour
certains sas en outre être en retour au
charbon ce qui serait évidemment une
catastrophe pour le climat pour d'autres
ça va sans doute accélérer la transition
vers les énergies renouvelables c'est
simplement absolument regrettable qu'il
ait fallu une guerre pour en arriver là
si nous avions mis en place la
transition énergétique il ya 20 ou 30
ans si nous avons été davantage
sensibles aux alertes sur le changement
climatique nous ne serions pas
aujourd'hui dans cette situation oui on
parlait du charbon peut aussi parler du
gaz liquéfié qui est une alternative
mais qui coûte cher en termes de qui
coûte cher tout court et puis qui coûte
cher aussi à acheminer en termes de de
ce que ça coûte au climat est ce que
vous êtes de ceux justement qui
pensaient que le curseur va plutôt aller
d'un point de vue général en europe vers
une accélération vers une transition
écologique contrainte et forcée ou
précisément vers à une marche arrière
j'ai tendance à croire et espérer que ça
va plutôt accélérer la transition vers
les énergies renouvelables notamment
parce qu'il est ici un argument de poids
c'est à dire qu'on réalise que cette
transition s'impose non seulement pour
répondre au défi du changement
climatique mais s'impose également pour
des raisons de sécurité des raisons
géopolitiques et qu'elle va s'imposer
aussi pour des questions simplement de
pouvoir d'achat on voit aujourd'hui les
prix de l'énergie qui sont en train
d'exploser sur les marchés de gros ce
qui expose également en ce moment
françois gemenne et et particulièrement
depuis le début de cette guerre en
ukraine ce le prix des denrées
alimentaires les cours du blé notamment
qui flambait ce que cet inquiétant est
ce qu'il faut s'en inquiéter et est ce
que c'est ça qu'on appelle les risques
de guerre chaude qui est le titre de
votre dernier ouvrage absolument
absolument on a vu par le passé
plusieurs mouvements sociaux plusieurs
révolutions en afrique notamment être
directement liée à l'augmentation des
prix des denrées alimentaires il faut
rappeler que le printemps arabe au
départ commence en tunisie par des
mouvements de protestation contre la
hausse des prix de l'alimentation il
faut rappeler que la guerre en syrie
comment souci par des protestations
contre la hausse du prix des denrées
alimentaires et de l'immobilier et donc
on voit à quel point cette question de
la faim et du prix des denrées
alimentaires peut être génératrice de
mouvements sociaux et on sait
malheureusement que de très nombreux
pays notamment en afrique du nord
dépendent directement du blé russe et
donc il ya un vrai risque de
déstabilisation également pour ces pays
et en ça est ce qu'il y à des
alternatives sur le court et le moyen
terme
sur le court terme toutes les
alternatives seront des emplâtres sur
des jambes de bois puisque nous n'avons
pas du tout préparé
cette autonomie cette indépendance à la
fois énergétique et et alimentaires et
donc ça va se traduire certainement par
une augmentation des coûts à la fois des
coûts de l'énergie mais aussi des coûts
de l'alimentation sur le long terme on
voit bien aujourd'hui l'urgence qu'il y
a à préparer ces stratégies nous aurions
dû le faire bien avant et quelque part
c'est notre défaut d'anticipation qui
nous place aujourd'hui dans cette
situation de grande dépendance vis-à-vis
la russie et qui risque d'empêcher les
européens par exemple de prendre des
sanctions plus fortes comme les
américains pour se passer du gaz ou du
pétrole russe pour essayer de résumer
tout ce qu'on vient de se dire françois
gemenne est ce que vous diriez que cette
guerre en ukraine en plus de son coût
humain terrible bien sûr est un est un
est un accélérateur de l'histoire
européenne comme jamais presse qu'elle
n'en a connu
très certainement on voit que toute une
série de lignes sont en train de bouger
radicalement on a vu que les lignes en
matière de défense européenne avait
bougé peut-être que les lignes en
matière de politique d'asile et
d'immigration vos bouge également est
certainement celle en matière de
politique énergétique également et donc
effectivement c'est un accélérateur
aussi de transformation dans l'union
européenne merci beaucoup merci françois
gemenne d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin depuis bruxelles on voit ces
drapeaux européens derrière vous
rappelle le titre du livre que vous avez
co dirigé qui est sorti aux presses de
sciences po plus que d'actualité la
guerre chaude merci encore et